how does a filmmaker know how much to
spend in order to get their money back
great question this is where
filmmakers you know get upset with
distributors because
they usually get screwed by distributors
that's the truth because distribution is
a whole different
business mindset they don't have the
you know the the sensitivity to
filmmakers
but distributors do serve a very good
function in the in the
industry i mean they do know how much a
movie is worth
where to monetize it where to sell it
and they have a pretty good idea of how
much they're going to get for it
so the best way to find out you know
what sort of
the range will be will be through a
distributor
now there are sales agents who do
these forecasts for you they give you
these ranges most indie films when
they're
you know trying to get financed they'll
get a sales agent to do a range
i've seen so many of them i don't know
if you've seen them but there's the low
the middle and the high sometimes
there's five of them right
their forecasts based on you know other
like films or comparisons i mean you
have to be super careful that you're
comparing it to like films
in the same sort of time frame like
sometimes they'll compare to like films
that were released 10 years ago
well i mean 10 years ago was a
completely different market than today
right
so you want the comps to be as you know
accurate as possible
but they'll do these comparisons and
they'll say you know the middle range is
sort of what you can expect
and it sort of is what you can expect i
mean these are people that do this for a
living
they know where ultimately they're going
to sell it
what the market will bear you know
internationally and from each player
and they do forecasts that give you a
pretty good idea
not dead on but at least a range and
that that's the best way to
gauge it so similar to how a realtor
would run
comps on on well this is a fixer and
it's this is
the square footage and so i think yours
will go for this or this one is
you know you've just redone the kitchen
and bathroom and you've got a huge lot
similar correct that's exactly the same
thing i mean i think real estate's a
little bit more
predictable and accurate because his
confined area you know
whereas film is the whole world but it's
the same concept
does that mean if i pick up the phone
and just call a distributor they'll give
me an idea of what my budget should be
um not necessarily i mean we should talk
a little
bit about distributors and how to find a
distributor and you know who's reputable
and who will give you you know the right
answer
assuming they'll even answer your phone
call
there are one you can pay for this there
are services that provide that
they charge a lot and i think they're a
bit of a rip-off i mean i only think
that because i do my own forecast based
on my own you know market knowledge
um but if you don't have any access to
anything else then you can pay for that
um and i forget there's some big
companies that actually do that
they provide those forecasts and they do
comp reports i mean
you know they're fancy and they give you
the whole thing and you take those to
investors and say here i got this report
done from
this company who specializes in this and
they're credible
um there's sales agents so there's a
difference between a sales agent and a
distributor i mean that line is
sort of crossing over these days a
little bit more
um but an agent let's say this is what
they can
tell you sort of what to expect um
and they're easier to get to than
distributors a distributor
generally wants to look at the movie
when it's finished
and that's why they're harder to get to
they don't really want to look at the
script or the idea or be pitched on it
they would be able to tell you and if
you can get to them you know
and we can talk a minute about how to
get to them then you can say i want to
make a
you know a 800 000 horror film and it's
gonna have
this number of special effects and no
talent then they can say
expect to get you know eight hundred
thousand or a million or whatever they
they could they could say they could say
that in
off the cuff over a coffee they don't
need to go and do analysis or anything
like that these people know this
in you know this is what they do so how
do you get how do you find a distributor
and how do you get an
honest answer it's getting tougher and
tougher to find a reputable distributor
first of all that business is getting
tougher so i mean this
the world is changing people's viewing
habits are changing so
so consumption of movies is changing i
mean
a lot of it now is through the streamers
through the
subscription video on demand services
the netflix the hulu's you know the
disney pluses
it's easy for consumers they're spending
you know
five to ten dollars a month and getting
an incredible array of
fantastic product it's made movie
watching such a pleasure
and television look at the quality of
product they're getting on some of these
i mean it's incredible
the amount you know that these streamers
spend on product because it's a volume
game they can afford it right
so that's making distribution top more
difficult so distributors are
falling by the wayside also so they're
getting far and fewer between
and they generally want to deal with
bigger budget product
they're not crazy about dealing with low
budget product for the same reason a
real estate agent
is not as crazy about you know doing a
hundred thousand dollar
rent sale than a five million dollar
sale same amount of work
much less commission so they want to
deal with bigger stuff because you know
they'll make more money off of it but to
find a reputable distributor
i mean you know you start um
there's different ways you can go about
it depending on who you are and what
your resources are
i mean you can go to a market like the
american film market or something like
that register for it
it's not cheap but that will give you a
access to all the distributors who are
registered there plus
access to their guide who's registered
in the american film marketing
association
you can do the same with say you know
read medium who runs mip.com or that
type of thing
so once you get into their database like
when you register
as a buyer or seller or whatever an
attendee for a major market like that
the value is half the value's going to
the market and you know hobnobbing and
seeing what goes on the other half is
having access to the database
so then now you have this say with the
case of miptv
or mipcom um you know there's
two to three thousand distributors in
that book
and in their database so now you gotta
contact them you gotta reach out
and it's like any type of networking you
you
try to be brief explain you know that
your filmmaker making this kind of movie
here's what it's going to be you know
dress it up a little bit you got to sell
yourself a bit
and say you just want to you're
interested in taking it to them
after the movie is finished but you want
to get an indication of sort of what
budget range you should be working in to
make sure that
you're not gonna you know you have a
chance of actually recouping and they'll
some of them will be cooperative like
anything else in the world you know half
of them will be rude
and the other ones you know you then you
just hopefully get lucky and you
get somebody on the phone who's you know
nice and they'll give you
they're not even on the phone through an
email or whatever the case may be
and if you can't do it that way you're
gonna have to pay to get a report
and and with this report some of the
comps again special effects
no name talent what about like locations
how many locations you plan to shoot
things like that
um is that is that factor in everything
factors in depending on who you get
because
it's also subjective but it doesn't
really totally factor in i mean the main
component is talent if you have a
certain level of talent then
it elevates it into a different category
see
like there are there's there's ranges
it's not you know like a total linear
thing
so in my i personally think and again
this is just
everything just my opinion right okay
but from my experience
if you're dealing in low-budget indie
films stay below
about 1.5 maximum
i used to say 2 million but 1.5 max
because the market is getting tougher
and tougher and tougher to monetize that
between 1.5 if once you start getting
into that
if you don't have major talent like at
least somebody who is recognizable
then you're better off jumping into 5
million
like between 1.5 and 5 is almost no
man's land
unless you can figure out how to get
talent in there you have a better chance
of getting your money back if you do it
say a five million dollar movie that has
name
talent then you do of doing a three
million dollar movie that's really
really well done but doesn't have name
talent
because talent sells talent's a huge
fact most distributors
the first question they ask is who's in
it and the reason that's they asked that
is because most consumers
ask that they say hey i heard this movie
who's in it
that's 90 of what people ask who's in it
and when they when they recognize
somebody they might take a chance with
it
so if you do go to afm uh or or mipcom
or something like that
then you you would look at the
distributors and make sure you're
reaching out to ones that are going to
be in your genre like don't if you have
a rom-com don't go to only
horror yeah and if you have a narrative
don't go to a documentary you know
district some people only specialize in
factual some and you know non-scripted
you know
yeah there are those are all listed also
they're all categorized people
when they list when the distributors
list in the in the databases
you know they fill out a form and they
say this is who we are this is what we
sell this is what we specialize in
yeah so so try to you know hone in on
that on the distributor that would
be you know more most suitable to what
you're making and keep the email brief
it's funny i'm talking so much right now
but generally
i write super brief emails and i keep my
correspondence super brief
and that's because we live in a world of
super short attention spans now i mean
people don't like to read a lot
everything's sound bites everything is
super quick everything is you know
twitter feeds and and instagram posts
and stuff like that it's all
super super short and with younger
executives
who you know are now used to all this
technology
they just don't want to read long emails
and don't want to hear long pitches and
all this kind of stuff
get to the point quickly
you